quand j'étais jeune avocat je le faisais
des collectes et 22 tableaux pour et des
marchés chaput qui à ce moment nous
fallait des jeunes pour la les
dépendances du québec militants
indépendantistes de la première heure au
sein du ralliement national
il a été un des membres fondateurs du
parti québécois puis député fiers
représentants du saguenay de 1973 à 1985
il était un des hommes de confiance de
rené lévesque
il aimait bien passer des soirées à
jouer aux cartes avec lui un homme
affable sans malice politicien respecté
marc andré bédard a été leader
parlementaire et vice premier ministre
du québec le député de chicoutimi
monsieur marc-andré bédard sera ministre
la justice mais c'est surtout à titre de
ministre de la justice qu'il a fait sa
ba dans le procureur général
je ne peux le faire il a mené
d'importantes réformes notamment celles
du code civil du droit de la famille et
de la charte des droits et libertés de
la personne du québec une privilégiée
d'une façon spéciale les assemblées de
cuisine
quant à qu'avec
les militants et a donné les résultats
que vous savez le retour ne se
ressentait 10 face à jose interroge pour
ça il a joué un rôle crucial dans les
référendums de 1980 et 1995 il nous
rappelait encore récemment en présence
de son fils stéphane
le rôle central qu'il avait joué aux
côtés du leader de la campagne
référendaire de 95 lucien bouchard
l'émotion monte un et a traversé avait
dit moi ce que je souhaite avant tout
c'est moins québec debout et ses 2000
est debout et pour qu'il le faisait
avait littéralement électrisé la salle
l'idée de la souveraineté pour moi a
toujours une idée était une idée de
cloche
si tu continues à te battre un moment
donné ça va aboutir
avez vous toujours ce sentiment ah oui
on verra aujourd'hui oui
la seule chose qui change c'est que ça
prince sa propre tête pleine forme pour
tout ce que vous avez accompli pour la
nation québécoise en 2013
il recevait le grade d'officier de
l'ordre national du québec des mets de
la première ministre
son ex-collègue pauline marois
on perd un grand homme très peu encore
plus chacun de savoir qui est qui sans
maître décédé de l'aco vide il était au
coeur même de toutes les politiques
gouvernementales de touléco chili à
bulles de toutes les confidences des
discussions y tient parce que y'a le
cabinet de la grande salle du cabinet
mais il ya des noyaux et au sein du
noyau il y avait un mac andré bédard qui
avec avait avec monsieur avec des
relations d'une affection du noyau tech
emparé au saguenay lac saint jean vous
est pris dès le monument que mes cheveux
doivent à présent je pense capable de me
rentrer dans take qui pilote marc andré
bédard était grandement impliqué dans sa
communauté
fervent croyant il était président des
concerts bénéfices d'avant noël à la
cathédrale de chicoutimi
cette année est désormais l'événement se
fera sans lui
et
[Musique]
jardin radio-canada m'ont rien